white house press secretary jensaki
joins us now good morning to you jen
saki reporting for good morning gail how
are you well i'm hanging in there
and reporting yes here in in beautiful
cornwall yeah you guys have a big week
coming up so i'm glad that the
the landscape looks good so far so good
listen we just heard from nancy cordes
that the biden administration is now
going to donate
500 million visor doses to countries
that need it most
how is that distribution going to work
well one it's a huge announcement and
we're in this position because we've had
so much success at home
uh vaccinating americans we've
vaccinated a greater percentage of
people in the united states than any
other country in the world so we're here
because of that this is going to be
distributed uh
gail through kovacs which is an
international organization that will
make sure it's distributed equitably
and to the countries that need help the
most so about 92 countries will be
benefited from these
from these doses the president's
announcing today hey janet's tony
decouple here good morning to you or
almost afternoon there in the uk good
morning tony
good morning i want to look ahead to
next week there's this highly
anticipated meeting with president putin
of russia
and on the agenda it would appear are
the recent cyber attacks exposing these
really frightening vulnerabilities in
american companies
really rattled americans overall how
does a president biden plan to address
those cyber attacks
with president putin because we
understand that the attackers were
inside russia
you're absolutely right tony and this
will definitely be a topic of
conversation a big topic of conversation
in the president's
meeting with president putin that's
happening next week and his message he's
going to be sending to president putin
is when you have these uh bad actors in
your country who are
doing harm to our infrastructure whether
it's hospitals
or pipelines or our meat supply
that you have a responsibility to take
action so that will certainly be a topic
of discussion
and one that will play a central role in
the meeting next week realistically
jen how are you all expecting this
meeting to go the president has been on
record as saying he believes
putin is a killer no surprise putin did
not appreciate that
do you have any icebreakers plan how do
you think this is going to go it's
starting off very frosty
and the world is watching
well i will tell you gail that the
president's focus is on
delivering messages that are important
to the american people
and using this meeting as an opportunity
to move our interests forward so
it's not about friendship they have
known each other for a long time they
have a lot of disagreements
but this is going to be a candid
conversation it's going to be a
straightforward conversation
the president's going to raise areas
where he has concern whether it's the
ransomware attacks or
the aggression on the border of ukraine
or human rights abuses
but there are also areas we think we can
work together nuclear stability we
signed an extension of new start
russia is an important partner as it
relates to the iran nuclear deal where
negotiations are ongoing
so we want to move to a more stable and
predictable relationship
that's in our interest we don't want it
to be adversarial and always heightened
and that's what we're hopeful this will
be the beginning of the start to
hey jen while we have you i do have a
question uh about american politics and
in particular the infrastructure bill a
lot of people have been watching its
progress or lack thereof and there's
criticism
from the progressive wing of the
democratic party uh saying
why is president biden working with
republicans at all on this it's clearly
a futile effort so why continue to push
for a bipartisan bill when you could
just
go it alone through reconciliation
well first let me say the president's
focus is on
getting this work done getting an
infrastructure bill a jobs bill signed
into law
getting child tax credit extended
ensuring there's universal pre-k
and we're moving on number of paths so
he's working with republicans and
democrats there's a couple of
negotiations happening in the house and
senate now
that's progress that's an encouraging
sign and we'll see where
that goes and he's doing that because
that's what the american people elected
him to do
to find areas of compromise to find
areas where there's common grounds
but his only red lines here tony are in
action
and raising taxes on people making less
than four hundred thousand dollars a
year so i can assure you
he's gonna we're gonna move on many
paths we're gonna see what can come out
of these negotiations but we're
continuing to move
through on a reconciliation path until
we have that option available as well
all right safe travels on the road big
week for the biden administration when
you return back to the states in the
heights is opening i highly recommend it
thank you
you're welcome for this video i'm
looking forward to seeing it all right
thank you
thank you both